[Musique]
vendredi 7 juin on peut en parler de
températures estivales à montréal en
tout cas il fait 24 degrés en fin de
semaine on parlera aussi de toc de
belles températures
ça pourrait monter jusqu'à 29 dimanche
scénario presque identique à toronto où
ce vendredi 25 degrés samedi soir à
peine du et dimanche 26 vancouver
vendredi et samedi c'est de la pluie
avait des températures le 16 et 19
degrés il va faire beau et chaud en
début de semaine sa peine du est là
messieurs bonjour bienvenue à tam tam à
mes côtés raymond des marteaux bonjour
et bon voilà mourad jilala qui est
historien je reprends mourad d'ibaraki
brin historien et professeur au collège
militaire royal de saint-jean au québec
bonjour
et puis monsieur nicolas rémy erquy
président et chef de la direction de la
conférence de montréal bonjour bonjour
alors plus tard on aura aussi la visite
de ellis quinn qui est responsable de
notre site intitulé regards sur
l'arctique et aussi de de guy bois qui
lui s'occupe qui chef de pupitre deux
espaces autochtone la banque ça va être
un menu assez intéressant comme
d'habitude à tam tam alors donc
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on va faire on
va essentiellement dresser le bilan de
l'enquêté nationale sur les femmes
d'autochtones disparues et assassinées
on va mettre la table sur la conférence
de montréal qui s'ouvre lundi ici à
montréal
on évoquera une distinction que a obtenu
notre collègue ellis queen de rien sur
l'arctique mais d'abord retour sur le
grand événement de la semaine
c'est-à-dire la commémoration du
débarquement des forces alliées en
normandie sas étaient polis béret la
france le 6 juin 1944
[Musique]
voilà donc un extrait d'un documentaire
sur la libération de la france
mourad debbabi la brand vous êtes
historien et professeur au collège
militaire royal de saint-jean au québec
bon alors c'est maintenant qu'on a
marqué cet événement ce 75e anniversaire
un événement très important pour la
france pour lolo g pour le monde de
façon générale mais pour les historiens
quelle est la place de cet événement là
pour vous de façon dire quand vous
regardez ça comme l'historien d'un point
de vue militaire
pour l'historien c'est un événement qui
est majeur dans la mesure où cette tv
tellement la première étape vers la
libération de l'europe de l'ouest
pendant ce temps vous avez les combats
qui sont menées à l'est sur le front
russe des combats qui sont menées
également qu'on oublie souvent en italie
les alliés remonte la péninsule
italienne mais l'europe de l'ouest et le
nord ouest de l'europe était toujours
sous la botte nazie depuis 1940 donc
pour les histori ghana point de vue
historique
c'est vraiment la première étape vers la
libération de l'europe
alors pendant ce temps il ici au canada
à bord on sait que lors de la première
guerre mondiale ya eu la fameuse
séquence que la circonscription lorsque
je pense que la conscription pardon la
conscription donc de 1917 1918
est-ce qu'on a eu le même phénomène pour
la vision guerre mondiale alors au
canada tout d'abord le premier ministre
de l'époque monsieur mackenzie king a
tiré des leçons de la conscription de
1917 1918 qui avait creusé littéralement
un fossé entre la population canadienne
française la population canadienne
anglaise donc la génération la deuxième
guerre mondiale ne l'oublions pas être
la génération qui a vécu la première
guerre mondiale également donc le
premier ministre de l'époque va essayer
d'éviter ce genre de tension en 1940 il
met en place une forme de conscription
mais juste pour le service au pays
le premier ministre s'est engagé à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas d'envoi de conscrits
outre-mer néanmoins à compter de 1942 et
après le débarquement en italie en 1943
les pertes canadiennes commencent à être
de plus en plus importante les canadiens
participent au bataille en italie la
paille d'ortona par exemple mais l'une
des plus meurtrières et donc le premier
ministre subit les pressions notamment
de son ministre de la défense
un canadien anglais qui veut
véritablement que le premier ministre
revienne sur son engagement
du début de la guerre savoir ne pas
envoyer de conscrits en europe et donc
en 1940 2 le premier ministre va lancer
un référendum demandant aux canadiens de
le délié de sa parole une fête au début
de la guerre et là encore on retrouve
finalement les mêmes tensions car en
1917-18 et le même clivage le québec va
voter à 80 % +2 81% contre le fait
d'envoyer des conscrits outre-mer et le
reste du canada anglais va voter à plus
de 80% pour envoyer les conscrits
outre-mer soutenir les canadiens qui se
battent en europe donc par contre ce qui
est intéressant c'est que le premier
ministre même s'il a laval desquels le
feu vert des canadiens pour enrayer les
construit va le faire le plus tard
possible
il va attendre 1944 quand justement les
canadiens et le premier armées
canadiennes va participer à la
libération de l'europe pour envoyer les
premiers conscrits en europe non qui va
essayer de le faire le plus tard
possible et les réticences du côté du
canal offre france s expliquer par quoi
bonne question
les historiens sur laquelle historiens
se pencheront il réfléchit beaucoup il
ya une question culturelle
les canadiens français les québécois
sont plus nord américain que le reste
des canadiens anglais je dirais le lien
culturel et canadiens anglais plus
proche la grande bretagne que le lier à
des québécois et canadiens français avec
la france d'ailleurs l époque on disait
les canadiens les anglais s'est servi
canadiens les canadiens étaient le
canadien les canadiens français étaient
bien pu nord américain que ne l'était le
média anglais donc pour eux n'y avait
pas brutalement d'intérêt à aller se
faire tuer en europe pour des pays qui
finalement était pour des pays étrangers
alors que pour un canadien anglais il y
avait le lien culturel souvent
d'ailleurs regard d'une immigration plus
récentes pour les canadiens au delà il
avait encore de la famille en angleterre
on pourrait y avait un intérêt plus
personnel et c'est encore plus de
lempire également d'où il ya également
gabin il faut faire attention aussi
parce que l'esprit de l' empire a
également évolué après la première
guerre mondiale en 1931 vous avez le
statut de westminster le canada est
dorénavant une nation donc à quand même
cette idée de nation canadienne qui est
mise de l'avant et doit être appuyée
d'ailleurs durant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
monsieur mackenzie king va faire en
sorte que les troupes canadiennes soit
identifié comme canadienne et non pas
comme intégré c'est ça des corps mort
lors de la première guerre mondiale
alors si ce mouvement là qui va faire en
sorte qu'après 945 justement le canada
va avancer vers cette idée de nation
canadienne sur la scène internationale
et après la guerre donc avec la victoire
enfin vichy qu'on connaît est ce que on
a une perception finalement de toute
cette aventure ici disons la population
inscrit finalement eu un un regard plus
positif de l'expérience ça c'est
difficile à dire disons qu'après la
guerre les populations veulent tourner
la page
c'est un peu ce qu'on appelle l'après
guerre les cas les vétérans qui rentre
au pays la plupart ne parlent pas donc
on regarde souvent ça pour soi
ensuite c'est dans l'après-guerre
également c'est le boom économique
l'énigme le canada donc profite donc de
cette économie des années cinquante
années 60 dont claire tu as quand même
l'idée du souvenir ça c'est certain
au niveau du 11 novembre qui est plus
présente d'ailleurs au canada anglais
qu'au canada français ce n'est que
récemment finalement qu'au québec on
s'intéresse véritablement à nos vétérans
j'ai d'ailleurs été assez surpris de
voir que pour 6 juin le premier ministre
du québec avait invité des vétérans à
l'assemblée nationale chose qu'il a
probablement 40 ans donc on n'aurait
jamais vu donc il ya quand même un
changement une évolution qui se fait au
niveau du rapport des francophones des
québécois à leurs anciens combattants et
à leur rapport à l'histoire militaire
finalement là je vous dirais que c'est
un peu le travail des historiens
justement on travaille là-dessus essayer
justement de re mettre en lumière la
contribution des canadiens français à
l'histoire militaire
c'est un mouvement qui a été engagé en
1994 justement avec les 50 ans du
débarquement de normandie est un élément
qui est intéressant également c'est que
puisque les vétérans disparaissent
progressivement c'est aux historiens de
prendre leur place et donc dû justement
de mettre de l'avant cette histoire que
on oublie que trop souvent au québec et
aussi de placer cet événement dans son
contexte historique mondial parce que de
fait il ya eu le premier pas de mettre
un pied premiers jalons sur le
territoire européen et non plus
exclusivement en grande bretagne mais il
y avait de l'autre côté staline qui
poussait très fort et depuis quoi deux
ans tous à ouvrir le front oui c'est en
effet il ya le contact politique il ne
faut pas oublier cela ligne depuis 41 20
depuis que tu as fait classe et une
tournée vers contre l'urss
le 22 juin 1941 staline qui pousse les
alliés churchill et à aider nos joueurs
à ouvrir un second front à l'ouest pour
essayer de diminuer la pression
allemande sur le front de l'est
en 43 les britanniques les américains
ouvrent un front qui est surtout voulu
perdre sur tille en italie pour attaquer
ce qu'il appelle le ventre mou de
l'europe donc les italiens qui
finalement sortent du conflit et les
américains tiennent plutôt à attaquer du
côté du nord-ouest de l'europe en
normandie donc avéré le contexte
politique important il y avait eu le thé
le terrible iv demain également de dire
ou si il ya également d'y être en août
c'est un peu le test finalement parce
que l'erreur de bongo mais c'est ça
c'est un test ça vous les erreurs de
diète en fait on paie à donner des
leçons pour le débarquement de 1944
parmi les leçons ont retiré retirer de
dieppe c'est qu'il ne fallait pas
attaquer un port il y est encore
fortement défendu c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs que l'on faisait en 44
d'attaqués sur des plages donc ça c'est
un peu les leçons de dieppe les autres
leçons de dieppe s'est également de
précéder la tacc le débarquement de
bombardements intensifs sur les défenses
ennemies ce qui n'avait pas été
nécessaire suffisant en 1942 donc là
encore ce sont des leçons de dieppe un
peu long quand à dia vous aviez 5000
canadiens qui ont participé mais ça sent
ont été tuées trois mille ont été faits
prisonniers
assez peu sont rentrés en grande
bretagne dont en effet d'y apparaître un
peu un aperçu de ce que pouvait être 44
et a permis de tirer des leçons pour le
6 juin donc tout cela vous disiez que
bon ça fait vous qu'elle est aussi le
devoir de mémoire étant donné que les
acteurs principaux centres de
disparaître avec le temps
est ce que les choses qu'on devrait
savoir à propos de cet épisode de
l'humanité cette guerre-là comme dont on
ne parle pas souvent et qui mérite
peut-être d'être reçue qu'il n'existe
rien peut-être pour vous l'historien
simple on oublie peut-être assez souvent
c'est les victimes civiles
il ya quand même plus de 20000 enfin là
aussi les historiens ne sont pas
d'accord au moins de 20 milles à 50
mille victimes civiles des villes comme
caen saint lô le havre ont été
totalement détruites et aussi un autre
événement qu'on ne pas beaucoup dont on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé c'est l'opération
fortitude
début juin 44 us dépôt des bus au début
de l'année 44 pardon jusqu'à début juin
1944 les alliés mènent une opération
d'intoxication des forces allemandes on
va leur faire croire que le débarquement
aura lieu à calais ou pas de calais
c'est ça et pour ce faire donc on va
mettre en place des faucheurs défaut
avions construits en matière non fiable
en carton mais également on va faire des
bombardements dans la région du nord pas
de calais donc des victimes civiles un
peu inutile mais qui permettait de faire
croire aux allemands que le débarquement
aurait lieu dans cette zone si et ça a
marché d'ailleurs puisque même le jour
du débarquement les allemands ont mis du
temps avant d'envoyer des renforts en
normandie pensons toujours que c'était
une opération de diversion et que le
débarquement aurait lieu et à quand il y
avait un général un maître d'oeuvre de
la wehrmacht
quand même qui était un rebelle en effet
bien fait trop mal et sur le mur de la
gentille depuis la fin 1943
donc lorsque les allemands perdent la
bataille en afrique du nord
adolf hitler en voie romaine sur le mur
de l'atlantique en fête le mur de
l'atlantique étaient avides et 1941
après le débarque la tentative de
débarquement de dieppe les allemands
vont nous renforcer 20 43 à l'afp claire
et envoie le général rommel pour
renforcer encore et défense est lui-même
le général rommel va croire que les
alliés débarquent seront plus au nord et
d'ailleurs après le débarquement jeunes
un roman sera blessé puis sa voiture
soit mitraillé dans un avion britannique
alors dites moi ben on l'a souvent on a
qualité cette guerre de der des ders la
dernière guerre aujourd'hui quel tel que
voyaient les choses
est ce que parce que toutes les guerres
ont des signes avant coureurs est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut se dire que mon
la troisième guerre mondiale n'est pas
l'horizon
en tant qu'historien gelé pour répondre
à cette question je voudrais pas sur le
passé mais disons que la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est plus la première guerre mondiale
dr la deuxième guerre mondiale n'a pas
mis fin aux tensions puisque tout de
suite à la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale 46,47 vous avez la guerre
froide qui débutent les alliés d'hier
deviennent les ennemis les nouveaux
ennemis d'aujourd'hui
la cour a suivi de l'accord et
enseignants 3 donc les tensions n'ont
pas disparu pour autant voir et se sont
même encore plus importante
qu'auparavant avec la nouvelle arme qui
est la bombe atomique lancée par les
américains 45 au japon et dont les yeux
les russes les soviétiques vont
également avoir leur propre monde donc
mais ce qui est important surtout pour
la génération de la deuxième guerre
mondiale c'est que ça et éventuellement
un traumatisme pour ces populations
notamment le traumatisme lorsque l'on
est redécouvert les camps de
concentration les politique
d'extermination nazis donc pour toute la
culture européenne je pense et le
rapport de l'europe à la guerre ça a été
un traumatisme qui a fait en sorte que
l'on a beaucoup appuyé à la génération
de la deuxième guerre mondiale a
beaucoup appuyé la construction de
l'union européenne puisque le trouve par
contre assez surprenant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui même pas 80 ans après
cette nouvelle génération n'a pas su
tirer des leçons deuxième guerre
mondiale quand on voit ces votes de
sortir la grande-bretagne de l'europe
sortir la france de l'europe ou voir
tout ces commentaires négationniste que
l'on voit sur les réseaux sociaux
je trouve assez déplorable assez triste
de voir que la mémoire finalement c'est
face à ces vies qui n'a pas eu de lien
qui se fait entre nos grands parents il
finira sur la deuxième guerre mondiale
et puis cette nouvelle génération des
réseaux sociaux de l'internet des fêtes
news comme on dit non mais qui remet
tout en cause
souvent on dit que l'on n'apprend pas de
l'histoire mais j'ai l'impression
aujourd'hui en tout cas que on a oublié
beaucoup de leçons tel deuxième guerre
mondiale et comment senna est ce que
vous avez l'impression justement que
l'histoire et sont perçus comme des
choses anciennes qui ne nous qui ne
regardent pas qu'ils ne regardent pas
écoute et pas voir de la part des
étudiants certains d intérêt à vous dire
comme je dis tous trois mille nuances et
clis l'histoire est omniprésente de
porte ou si vous voulez comprendre le
monde contemporain les relations france
etats unis les relations grande bretagne
etats unis c'est dans l'histoire que
voulait comprendre et l'histoire
ouvertement la base de tout l'histoire
fait pas seulement des dates et
également des contextes des relations
comprendre la relation le continent
africain avec le continent européen vous
ne pouvez pas le comprendre si vous ne
connaissez pas l'histoire la
colonisation et de la décolonisation ans
que l'histoire est terminée
et vous parliez de devoir de mémoire se
sait pertinemment parce que je suis un
fils d'anciens combattants mon père
était était marin enfin la bataille de
l'atlantique
un convoi de russie et a fallu attendre
la fin de sa vie et mort très jeune pour
retrouver josé ici retrouvez les
médailles de papa que j'ai fait remonter
à son le monde et médaille de mon père
et ça vous savez la barrette sur une
médaille ça veut dire beaucoup ça au
canada ça veut dire bataille en zone de
combat zone de conflit donc il a fait ce
qu'on appelle la bataille de
l'atlantique est trop chauvin comme
c'est chez nous s'est présenté siens
vers pâques un hôtel à la maison mais
c'est pas tellement dans l'oubli dans le
quartier de bars et des vieilles choses
alors que non liszt le quotidien
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire de demain
et le lien indéfectible entre les deux
mais forcément la seconde attendre ce
que l'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans la
plupart dans sa compétence et que peu
parlent
après la guerre et la question du choc
post traumatique qu'aujourd'hui on
comprend un peu mieux mais l'afghanistan
et reda on a de plus en plus prises en
considération mais après la première
guerre mondiale après la deuxième guerre
mondiale les anciens combattants étaient
laissés à eux-mêmes pour avoir étudié
plus particulièrement la première guerre
mondiale dans les années 20 vous avez
des taux de suicide silence un
combattant ennemi considérable or les
journalistes qui rapporte la ne
comprennent pas aujourd'hui nous
reprenons ce sont les choc post
traumatique pour la deuxième guerre
mondiale les choses sont exactement les
mêmes
et souvent les solutions présent ces
combattants s'était se retrouver entre
parler de la guerre entre donc au niveau
des la légion canadienne la wii de la
guerre mais on est en famille c'est pas
du tout et aujourd'hui nous regrettons
même pas d'avoir pu faire parler nos
parents ou grands-parents de cette
personne de l'histoire c'est
générationnel
- non c'est 5 rarement mes enfants 9 ans
et 10 ans et il s'intéresse le jour j il
y avait une était un parle à l'école ma
génération j'ai 43 ans on n'en parlait
pas non on en parle est absolument pas
c'était
on commence à s'y intéresser ça fait dix
ans qu'on commence à s'intéresser
vraiment à l'aller à l'histoire
militaire
on a une histoire militaire qui est
riche mais on commence à s'y intéresser
on est plus intéressant une histoire
militaire américaine à certains égards
dans ma génération que notre propre
histoire militaire a new role qu'on a
joué on n'est plus au courant sur ao des
américains dans les grands conflits
mondiaux
quel bureau de nos profs militaire il
est aussi le cinéma mais ce qui est
intéressant concernant justement la
cérémonie du 6 juin 44 c'est que
jusqu'aux années 80 on ne célèbre pas
véritablement au 6 juin 44
c'est plutôt le président reagan qui a
retrouvé entre guillemets cet événement
dans une idée de mettre de l'avant les
états unis les états unis d'amérique et
j'avais lu d'ailleurs hier un sondage
franc intéressant c'est que au sortir de
la guerre les personnes les personnes
interrogées considérer l'urss comme
véritablement le pays qui avait permis
de gagner la guerre or très rapidement
durant la guerre froide et jusqu'à nos
jours
si vous demandez aux personnes qui a
permis de gagner la guerre nous ce sont
les états unis c'est un de ces questions
si de récupération du pain c'est bien
sûr la tous les dangers de la mémoire
d'ailleurs le site très intéressant
mourad du blabla je rappelle que vous
êtes historien et professeur au collège
militaire royal de saint-jean
merci beaucoup pour rester avec nous
alors on va passer maintenant
un événement qui est très attendu c'est
un événement mondial
on en parle on en parle pas souvent mais
c'est un événement compte tenu de
l'ampleur qu'il a qui mérite qu'on s'y
attarde un parc la semaine prochaine
s'ouvre à montréal la conférence de
montréal justement
et pour en parler le président et chef
de la direction de cette conférence
monsieur nicolas rémy à bonjour c'est du
billard jeux de lumières bon alors cette
conférence là elle existe depuis 1995
oui tout va voilà comment
c'est venu au monde va écouter c'est une
histoire de famille donc c'est mon père
qui était dans le gouvernement de robert
bourassa qui avait quitté la politique
et après il y avait eu l'idée de créer
une conférence c'était le début de
l'accord de l'om s'est alors il ya créé
cette première édition de la conférence
de montréal en 95 qui devait être une
édition seulement qu'ils devaient pas se
répéter et jean chrétien avait fait
l'ouverture de la conférence et on avait
à l'époque et on n'avait aucune idée qui
on avait vraiment on n'avait pas eu vent
que mais notre culture américaine était
quand même des fesses et des anecdotes
assez intéressant donc on n'avait pas
avant qu on avait des 10 économies ce
monsieur croc monsieur geoffrey sax que
tu as donc c'est une conférence qui se
voulait une conférence d'une édition
donc et ponctuel et après bon alors une
équipe s'est joint à la conférence a
grossi en est notre deuxième édition il
y avait un besoin si dans tout les
grands mouvements sociaux qui étaient là
pour ou contre la mondialisation les
nouveaux accords internationaux dans 95
jusqu'au début des années 2000 commerce
on parlait des grands accords
commerciaux alors il y avait un intérêt
le canada 20 excellente réputation
internationale c'est un endroit neutre
où on peut débattre de grand enjeu
international
moi je me rappelle des grandes
délégations africaines qui venait à la
la conférence de montréal qui aimait
venir la conférence mme qui aimait venir
au canada et à montréal donc c'est
vraiment l'origine de la de du forum des
amériques si la conférence montréal et
ensuite de ça on a mis en place un
conférence à toronto une amie amy et une
à paris maintenant et qui sait à qui
s'adresse cette conférence last
événement s'adresse à tout le monde
donne nettement vous avez des gens des
pme qui viennent là vous avez des
histoires que vous avez déjà des
commandes en anglais 10016 des mômes pop
shop
trois personnes d'une entreprise crédit
des tpe petites entreprises qui viennent
mais qui deviennent grande
on a des histoires des histoires à
succès qui sont venus une à deux
personnes qui y sont développées on est
moins cher qu'un billet d'avion simon c
- confié venir chez nous
que dalle et d'aller à l'extérieur des
grands voyages parce que c'est pas
l'organisation ont fait vos meetings on
vous organise des rencontres on vous
garantit que souvenirs chez nous à les
rencontrer du beau monde
alors on est excellent et très
accessible c'est pas élitiste il ya des
gens de toute l'histoire économique de
toutes les horizons d'investissement
vous dites qu'il ya des histoires à
succès mais je n'arrête justement
l'entente quelques-unes bah écoutez nous
l'établissement le souci d'une seule
fille
les contacts que vous avez créé les
contacts et les contacts c'est mes côtés
je voudrais que nous par exemple de
commencer c'était saisonniers moi
j'étais à l'université et puis je
plantais les drapeaux la première année
que ce que je faisais ils purent
n'ouvrez au mois de mars ont préparé la
conférence on fermait la la boutique si
on veut à partir du mois de juillet on
était dans un entresol travaux sur la
rue william
on est rendu plus d'une trentaine de
collègues d'envoyer au bureau donc ça
grossit il ya on a vu des compagnies
comme lavalin qui ont beaucoup pris
d'expansion qui ont fait des contacts et
extraordinaire chez nous on n'est pas
témoin des rencontres on se rencontre
souvent du résultat de la conférence
dans l'année qui suit on voit des
compagnies qui sont rencontrés parce
qu'on est au courant des bilatérales
mais c'est là qu'on voit le résultat
alors c'est on peut pas on peut pas
faire comme pépin se voit si c'est grâce
à nous que ces gens le sont mais c'est
notre contribution donc on est quel est
le grand avantage à cette forme de
réseautage sur place par opposition un
aux outils modernes qu'on peut avoir du
skype qu'on peut avoir du courriel
istres moi je vais vous raconter une
anecdote nous ne bougions si on l'est on
a des gens qui travaillent chez nous à
la conférence qu'ils sont c'est l'ère de
l'internet d'émerveillement moi j'ai
chanté entre les deux
le téléphone et puis l'internet car vous
appelez quelqu'un voulait faire un deal
vous le faire lors encore quand vous
envoyez un email à quelqu'un la personne
peut prendre une semaine pour vous
répondre tout vendre deux jours pour
faire revoir les immeubles par quatre
personnes pour s'assurer que tout est
correct parce que les écrits restent
quand vous appelez la personne vous
sentez la voix au téléphone vous avez
vous le savez si vous avez ou ça marche
ça marche de ma cave rencontrer
quelqu'un en personne vous le voyez il
devant vous ça vous voyez s'amorce à la
chimie est là ou si c'est pas là c'est
pour moi c'est ça ça vaut n'importe quoi
les skype on voit la personne on voit un
gestuel on voit une partie de de
l'individu les dessous c'est pas complet
alors là maintenant sont pas au niveau
des applications
alors il ya des applications qui existe
pour le réseautage donc non une
application aussi pour tous nos
événements mais il ya des gens qui sont
très gênés d'utiliser une application
parce que vous demandez leur encore vous
pouvez faire racheter
donc la personne est pas garanti que
personne de l'autre côté vous oui
j'accepte devrait rencontrer en arrière
de l'escale à terre ou un dans la salle
b troyes aube et quand vous avez aucune
garantie donc nous on a fait les deux
vous avez un service personnalisé pour
les gens dont vous êtes une compagnie
partenaire de la conférence de montréal
on organes on regarde votre chambre
expertise et on vous proposait encore
essentiellement le bus il faut se dire
encore hambourg le des livrables en bout
de ligne si on n'a pas rencontré nous
l'hiver ça va pas bien
l'enseignement est l'une des
caractéristiques de cette conférence de
montréal ce gamin que vous invitez des
très gros nord là c'est un autre exemple
on aura louise mushikiwabo qui est la
secrétaire général de la francophonie
la touriste québec françois legault et
plein d'autres alors donc ça c'est quand
même une des nouveaux marque de commerce
ouais ben tout à fait on essaye d'avoir
dans notre écosystème d'avoir dit des
très gros noms mon hobby en demi que
président fondateur le bio métier là on
a des gens de lift
on a des gens de toutes les sphères mais
déjà des balades intelligence
artificielle on ad on doit parler
d'intelligence artificielle à montréal
sam est contournable
mon à des sommités mondiales on a des
donc le but c'est pas d'avoir une
rencontre juste avec des gens des élites
dans différents domaines
mais c'est que ces gens là soient là à
la conférence est qui interagissent avec
tout le monde et c'est ça la beauté de
la conférence de montréal
est-ce que des grands thèmes qui se
définissent qui évolue au fil des années
d'aidés des cycles de cinq ans quoi pas
le commerce on parle commerce le
commerce équitable un moment donné est
ce qu'on peut remplacer le commerce
durable le commerce équitable on parle
d'investissements ça plus la même
définition qui a 5 à une évolution les
mouvements sociaux en une définition
beaucoup plus social
au terme de deux commerces à la pratique
du commerce sont regarde le financement
au niveau des grands fonds
d'investissement le début les
investissements durables de son ton
c'est des sujets de l'heure c'est ils
doivent adresser ces sujets-là cesser le
développement durable c'est partout
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un peu
une fille ça on en met partout dans tous
les sens à tout ça alors c'est ça qui
est c'est vraiment c'est plus ses
composantes
on parle de faits news par exemple mais
ces coiffes etc nous et ce à seulement
chaque personne a sa définition du feq
news chaque personne a sa teneur du fait
que nous sommes
alors c'est sûr qu'il ya des sujets qui
varie bien toujours des des piliers qui
restent qui sont des incontournables le
véhicule sur la finance de gouvernance
tout ça ça donne justement wallon va
votre site laminé le changement on
imagine que c'est quand même ça le pour
cette année c'est simple le thème
central by ceci est très largement je
pense que ça ça reflète beaucoup ce qui
se passe dans le monde et dans les temps
changements partout ont voté comme tous
les jolis avons les invités que vous
avez tout à fait et la palette est assez
large mais tout un kaléidoscope de la
orientations et politiques et
philosophiques us il ya tellement de
soucis pour tous les bonnes personnes
on essaie de se renouveler année après
année tout en gardant un bon noyau qui
revient
mais c'est des gens qui veulent
rencontrer du monde c'est des gens qui
veulent faire des affaires puis montréal
sim bellevue les gens adorent venir à
montréal
alors vous avez dit que l'on peut
constater c'est une histoire à succès
déjà vous fasse montréal est ce que
j'avais des ambitions pour plus tard ce
que vous aidez chose que vous aimeriez
encore jusqu'à l'examen l'accord
escaladé une pme on a toujours des
ambitions comme on dit on aller on peut
rêver mais on peut pas prendre est assez
gros pour réveiller le passé vous prend
des risques il faut faire attention à ce
qu'il vienne
ça s'est toujours bien géré on est un
peu comme les expos de montréal dans les
ligues majeures mon avis public
donc on a on a des aspirations on
aimerait bien faire une annonce irna
mais je pense que souvent on a envie
d'autres grandes villes en amérique du
nord mais quand on regarde vraiment
printemps regardez qu'est ce qu'on a
chez nous il dans quelle ville on habite
on se rend compte que montréal est un
outil de développement absolument
extraordinaire pour cela sur un nuage
vous remercie beaucoup d'être venus et
surtout très bonne conférence qui
commence lundi
c'est à montréal je vous conseille très
fortement d'aller faire un tour à cette
conférence la qui est extraordinaire at
royal a pour tous les goûts
et je sais de quoi je parle comme d'un
de mes anciens profs nickel besson à
lettres d'or sur vos tablettes de jade
merci étudiés
chez une personne quitter sa soeur elle
aimait rire elle aimait la vie
il avait plein de projets et d'horreur
[Musique]
oh
salah processus en deuil
c'est vraiment là processus anglais
surtout qu'un événement qui école qui
arrive comme ça que tu sais pas que
l'était pas malade
les terre pleins de santé que un
événement comme ça qui arrive que ça
fait
c'est beaucoup beaucoup mal compris là
on va parler maintenant du dossier du
rapport qui est sorti il ya quelques
jours sur l' enquête des femmes
autochtones femmes autochtones disparues
et assassinées et pour en parler des
bois qui est sûr de pupitre d'espacé
autochtone qui un peu à du canada le
site qu'ils s'intéressent aux qualités
autochtone bonjour dit oui beaucoup
guy de travail la commission ben on
était très très long fastidieux
c'est simple et un long fleuve
tranquille il ya eu des hauts et des bas
et pourtant on a ce rapport qui est
sorti est ce que au final c'est un
exercice qui aura été utile oh oui oh
oui pour être utile ça c'est sûr ça me
fera peut-être pas consensus à la fois
chez les partis politiques à la fois
chez les nations autochtones mais comme
exercice c'est utile parce qu'on a mis
des noms demi des visages sur des un
drame pas possible dans l'histoire quand
on pense qu'il ya 1200 femme autochtone
et ben le lait l'association des femmes
autochtones du canada parle plutôt de 14
ans qui ont été assassinées et disparues
alors on en est un problème en temps en
tant que nation aussi si on mettait ça
par exemple quand on pense qu'il
représente à peu près 4 % de la
population
si on met ce à l'échelle canadienne on
se retrouverait avec des villes moyennes
de 30 mille femmes qui auraient été
assassinés si elles avaient été des
canadiens donc c'est une proportion
incroyable et surtout ça a mis le doigt
sur un dysfonctionnement de la justice
parce que qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce que
nous a démontré sera sera par là
finalement et ils nous ont montré que
les femmes autochtones au canada le
rhode nier non seulement le droit à la
vie mais le droit à la sécurité
alors en quand elles sont en communautés
elles ont des problèmes parce que les
services policiers autochtones sont sous
financées et on le répète depuis des
années donc oublions la sécurité et
quand elles doivent quitter leurs
communautés et les jeux pour en parler
mieux points alors on parle par exemple
des famines weight qui se retrouve à
montréal
ils se retrouvent dans des situations de
vulnérabilité où elles seront
vulnérables à la fois des gens qui les
exploitent
la fois à la toque ce qu'elle
toxicomanie etc quand on voit la police
on n'y croit pas parce que la parole
d'une femme autochtone savent au moins
qu'une femme d'outrebon par exemple et
voilà ce rapport là on utiliser le mot
génocide
ça fait controverse aussi bon j'imagine
que dans l'acte dans les communautés on
a c'est agréable de campus qualifié ce
concept l'adamois aussi dans ce qui
s'est passé avec un concept aussi fort
que l'on mangé ce que j'aime aussi dit
oui
bon effectivement c'est fort mais il
faut il faut et c'est pour moi qui va
trancher le débat en est un où pas un
jeu saw aux experts mais ce qu'il faut
voir aussi ses intérêts politiques
d'utiliser le mot génocide
c'est que comme c'est une enquête qui
était fortement contesté par les
associations de femmes autochtones par
les nations autochtones et cetera il
fallait sortir avec un rapport qui est
fort et qui peut être plus fort dans les
conclusions que le mot génocide hier le
port on touche vraiment à quelque chose
d'important et en ceux de ça ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est la définition qu
ils ont rapporté ses opposants je suis
d'accord avec ça mais il faut juste voir
le processus qui a mené à l'utilisation
du mot jeunesse ce qu'on nous a dit
c'est que il faut mettre le mot génocide
dans un dans le cadre historique
processus de colonisation et on commence
d'abord par la distribution de
couvertures qui sont contaminés à la
variole
ensuite on saute et on s'en va dans
affamer les peuples de l'ouest en tuant
des bisons en restreignant en enfermant
les communautés d'inde en lit dans des
réserves
alors que c'était d'aidé pour plusieurs
nations des pêcheurs d'aider des
cueilleurs des chasseurs et c'est alors
et pour lille c'est jeannot c'est une
forme de génocide et ensuite on poursuit
au xxème siècle quand on rentrait dans
les communautés et comprenait des
enfants on les arrachaient des familles
mais ce n'est là qu'une enquête s'il
sait on vient chez vous on vous enlève
votre enfant parce que ce que vous allez
le
lui enseigner même si ça fait 1001 2001
que vous êtes sur place et que vous avez
une culture qui est tout aussi valable
que l'autre pendant dit non non votre
langue notre culture votre religion ça
vaut rien nous on va leur montrer de la
vraie religion
alors pour ces gens là c'est devenu une
forme de génocide et par attrait qu'on
pense au québec par exemple tout à coup
tu es malade est une femme se fait
soigner tueur retourne chez toi conte au
stérilisés et tu le sais même pas tous à
ces événements la répartie sur cinq ans
150 en 201 bain pour les gens c'est
devenu un génocide
quand une question taboue à mon sens ce
qui n'a pas été touché dans ce rapport
là où très peu qui toutes celles de la
responsabilité des hommes autochtones
parce que si effectivement les femmes
sont en situation de vulnérabilité
quand elles sont arrivées elles le sont
aussi quand elles le sont dans leur
communauté à l'heure où sont les hommes
autochtones pour montrer du doigt leur
propre responsabilité
c'est la responsabilité et ça les chapes
autochtones ont été assez timide sur
cette question juste un polar y est les
inuits ont même avant qu'elles enquêtent
été mise en place et beaucoup de
controverse dans l'acte de plupart des
animaux et au canada vit dans l'arctique
parce qu'il dit nous ça fait des années
on est comme dans les petites
communautés isolées
on sait la cause de violence on sait
qu'il a fait avec leur réalité et dit ce
qu'on a besoin c'est leurs ressources et
avec au début les plupart des
dirigeantes à l'époque is an 10 me pour
cette enquête pour nous on veut des
ressources on veut pas dépenser l'argent
sur une enquête mais il faut des yeux
que les audiences qui ont lieu dans
l'acte rick s'aérer les questions dans
les communautés s'est un peu levé le
fardeau le tour des silences dans leur
communauté est finalement le plus parler
des dirigeants et nous et était très
content avec le rapport parce que c'est
aussi ça visait la réalité et nous et
aussi
alors qui est ce que vous pensez que ce
rapport ont qualifié d'assez fort va
avoir des suites
ben pour l'instant je dois vous dire que
comme or encore en campagne électorale
que pour l'instant il se passera rien je
vous dirais que pour la prochaine année
il se passera pas grand chose
tout le monde votre tout le monde doit
être un campagne électorale focus et
pour la réélection soit du de l'ancien
gouvernement où l'élection d'un nouveau
gouvernement est dépendant des pâtis
aussi on comprend bien que les
conservateurs et les libéraux n'ont pas
la même vision des relations avec les
autochtones aussi donc ça risque d'être
un enjeu électoral
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par exemple avec
cet enjeu de la sécurité est ce que ça
ça va devenir un enjeu électoral ces
quatre pour cent de la population
canadienne qui est autochtone
on parle au québec de 3% est ce que est
ce que le poids démographique est ce que
le poids politique des autochtones est
assez fort pour influencer le vote pour
influencer les politiques connaissent en
histoire ou si des taux de participation
oui pourquoi là dessus c'est pas si pire
c est qu au provincial les autochtones
participe pour beaucoup parce qu'ils ont
l'impression que c'est leur gouvernement
mais vous voyez des dernières élections
parle d'une participation au tour de 60%
des autochtones là bas avec certains
comtés cependant qu' coup ils sont la
majorité pour le comté de roméo saganash
par exemple dans le nord-du-québec un
dans le nord de l'ontario
channing mais ils ont tendance à voter
surtout néo-démocrate beauté au fédéral
et beauté néo-démocrate sûr c'est la
grande tendance chez les autochtones et
ça existe depuis les années 60
je pense donc pour l'instant tout ça est
non seulement cette question des femmes
leur sécurité dit financement de la
police autochtone mais tout le reste
aussi un vous savez qui reste encore 50
communautés dans le nord par sûrement
dans le nord de l'ontario qui ne sont
pas desservis en eau potable qui a été
le comment dire la grande promesse des
libéraux ils ont quand même réussi à
livrer la moitié mais cccc difficile
cette situation hyper complexe
je me souviens d'un reportage moi qui
m'avait frappé de nos collègues du nord
de l'ontario
on voyait une jeune fille de 10 ans qui
pour la première fois buvait de l'eau
potable au robinet alors vous imaginez
et on parle du canada un pays qui est
qui qui des réserves d'eau douce
incroyable et qui fait la vie de la
plupart des pays dans le monde justement
sa réserve d'eau potable et de la ville
aux riches aussi et voilà est-ce que
vous pensez que cette crise l'or est
dure et une crise d'eau potable devrait
durer aussi longtemps heureusement on a
posé la question de ceux ci répondent
oui c'est ça guy bois merci beaucoup
même si je dis et le chef de pupitre
l'espace autochtone qui incite frère de
hervé et je vous conseille d'ailleurs
très fortement de consulter ces sites là
de le visiter parce que il ya beaucoup
d'informations sur les réalités
autochtones
merci voilà donc ça c'est l'extrait
sonore d'un dossier aussi préparé par
ellis quinn qui est mac ma collègue bon
jour ils y subissent donc qui s'occupe
du volet canadien de regard sur
l'arctique
alors justement pour ce dossier là vous
avez obtenu une mention honorable et qui
fait la fierté de tout le monde a essayé
c'était dans lequel ces cons c'est
d'avoir qui vous a offert la mention
mais c'est la fondation dirt aux états
unis c'est basé à new york et pisser
dans l'université de columbia
ils ont mis cette fondation en place
pour explorer comment la violence et le
tram 1 est traité dans le milieu
journalistique
je pense qu'on est tous d'accord si on
regarde quelques dessinée souvent avec
les violences les victimes l'histoire
est et socialiser victime était traitée
comme victime
et puis ils ont mis sept prix en place
pour pouvoir les projets ou les jeunes
disent qu'ils essaient de décortiquer
les villans juste le sans cesse les
l'expliqué le racing pourquoi et manque
comment les les victimes de tout ça ils
sont comme les survivantes et pas les
gens aient pu tutoyer mais les gens
respectés voilà est donc bon maintenant
est-ce que c'est eux qui ont trouvé
votre reportage mais c'est vous qui
l'avez soumises hâtif non il fait une
demande chaque année c'est ouvert à tout
les journalistes en amérique du nord et
mexique le canada puis aux états unis et
puis on se met une pluie ça prend des
lettres de ce que nous aussi
et puis on était chaque année deux
gagnants et deux mentions dans l'arrêt
et puis une url du canadien national
regard de la clique ont été choisis
comme un délai les ans seulement l'air
et puis on est très très fiers et
surtout pour un sujet comme ça
exactement un sujet assez grave mais sur
le fond de l'histoire est ce qu'on a des
suites passe comme une situation
dramatique ya eu morts oui c'est un
jeune qui était poignardé à mort au menu
big la région inuits du nord du québec
et puis on a suivi les familles pendant
week - pour voir comment est impacté par
le manque de services judiciaires manque
de sauver ce temps la santé mentale est
aussi le manque de services du coroner
du québec dans ces petites communautés
il faut dire que depuis que sa sortie en
décembre le
malheureusement les services saas arrive
pas et puis le procès est encore
rapporter rapporter rapporter il se pose
est d'avoir une dernière audience la
semaine prochaine c'était annulé à cause
du meet you alors on suivre ce dossier
il va voir une deuxième partie mais
comme ça c'est très très lent dans
l'arctique
voilà merci beaucoup et lycées fille oui
moi je pose une question pour régler
parce que j'avais peut-être pas à 30
secondes oui oui voilà me suit des cours
dit nous et aussi d'une petite ou qu on
commence à s'ennuyer ce sont bien le co
est terminée pour le moment mais je fais
mon possible continuer chaque fois voilà
donc merci a remercié les habitants qui
sont partis merci surtout à l'équipe
technique avec pier dutil benoît durand
karl boulanger et marc andré deschamps
alors quand à vous on vous dit merci
d'avoir été là et on se retrouve très
bientôt
au revoir bonne journée